bonjour à tous bienvenue sur ce live on
va suivre on va vivre vous faire le
point sur le mercato d'hiver puisqu'on
est dans la dernière ligne droite de ce
mercato il se ferme aujourd'hui c'est
blanc de faire des dernières affaires il
ya encore beaucoup de rumeurs chez avec
sébastien ferra du service des sports
salue sébastien salut vincent sait
comment ça va ça vient ça très bien une
journée assez chargé pourtant on imagine
ouais tout à fait grosse journée une
rougeur du mercato pour pour conclure un
mois très très actif à maman est très
dense même si le mercato hivernal
forcément c'est pas comme le mercato
estival mais il ya eu quand même des
belles signatures il ya encore des
grosses rumeurs on peut peut-être
commencer par parler du psg le psg avec
kilian end ap une info qui vient
d'allemagne il se serait mis d'accord et
ce serait bon pour cet été ouais une
info qui a surpris beaucoup de monde
parce que en soi n'a rien à voir avec le
mercato d'hiver pour le coup ce serait
pour pour l'été prochain bon le
feuilleton bape et on va pas retracer
toute l'histoire on la connaît le real
madrid qui le courtise depuis longtemps
qui avaient fait des offres l'été
dernier qui était monté jusqu'à 180
millions d'euros le psg qui avait dit
non il ne bouge pas en prenant le risque
de le voir partir à la fin de son
contrat en juin prochain au début du
mois il ya pas mal d'infos en france
notamment du parisien qu'il disait que
bape et n'excluait pas l'idée de
prolonger et là on apprend que le bape
et aurait dit oui au real madrid que ce
serait que ce serait ficelé que ce
serait fait alors on va quand même
attendre qu'il ya d'autres médias qui
confirme cette information parce que
assez un quotidien allemand bild qui
annonce un peu venu de nulle part en
plus à deux semaines de l'affrontement
et gérer des champions ça paraît un peu
surprenant maintenant on sait que le
feuilleton bape et il est loin d'être
éclaircis et que tant qu'on le verra pas
avec un maillot du real madrid il sera
encore parisien ça promet encore de gros
suspense pour les prochaines semaines
quand ça va encore durer à peu près six
mois à avoir des rumeurs toutes les
semaines ça est un peu sa wii 2 du côté
des arrivées
du psg on n'a rien vu encore de bien
incroyable en tout cas il ya une rumeur
persistante ces régions d'ousmane
dembélé ousmane d'amérique qui pourrait
revenir en france et jouer au psg est ce
que c'était c'est plausible est ce que
ça ça l'est encore ouais alors l'info
paraissait absolument pas plausible hier
soir lorsqu'elle est sorti dans la
foulée il ya eu beaucoup de démence et
en même temps ça paraît assez assez
incongru des informations qui
circulaient en tout cas tout journal
l'équipe sait que le psg le barça avait
discuté d'assez loin d'un éventuel
échange de joueurs parce qu'un transfert
pour le tg c'était compliqué on a
souvent dit on l'avait dit encore il ya
deux semaines le psg doit vendre doit
absolument vendre mais je ne peux pas
s'offrir démener comme ça en claquant
des doigts en tout cas pas steve r ça
paraît aujourd'hui une rumeur totalement
juste une rumeur quoi ça c'est
absolument pas crédible parce que le psg
ne peut pas en l'état s'offrir ousmane
dembélé sans parler de la question
sportive ça paraît totalement insensé
par rapport aux joueurs dont dispose
déjà paris de s'offrir dembélé qui a un
profil trop proche de 2 me pape et de
neymar ou de cette armada offensive
qu'il ya déjà
des semaines dembélé lee rapport paris
saint germain cet hiver ça c'est certain
puis surtout c'est comme un joueur qui a
encore des dp par physique qui est pas
toujours à toujours à 100% c'est quand
même un vrai pari si vous venez au psg
oui c'est un vrai pari et finalement de
façon ce sera un vrai pari peu importe
où l'irak ce soir à manchester united
chelsea qui sont cités comme peut-être
un petit peu plus chaussures sur le
dossier dembélé quoi qu'il arrive c'est
un joueur qui doit se relancer qui doit
aussi trouver son véritable rôle sa
vraie identité est ce qu'on est sur un
client bébé ou est-ce qu'on est sur un
joueur de moindre calibre j'ai
l'impression que c'est plutôt cette
deuxième option en tout cas même sur ces
derniers matchs au barça où il a enfin
pu enchaîner où il était un peu loin des
blessures ou xavi vers fait beaucoup
confiance dans le jeu on a vu un joueur
très fort très en confiance mais qui ne
pouvaient pas décider du destin d'un
match qui ne pouvait pas porter une
équipe comme le barça sur plusieurs
matchs sur la durée comme peut le faire
qui la battait au psg ou en karim
benzema au real madrid pour prendre un
autre français en plus aussi en espagne
on se bat de mai mais l'on sait pas s'il
est vraiment ces catégories là où tout
cas il n'a pas l'air de l'être sur les
quatre cinq saisons je crois maintenant
qu'il aura c'est au barça n'a jamais
prouvé ça mais c'est un joueur qui peut
tout à fait se relancer en angleterre et
être les meilleurs du monde à son poste
parce qu'il souhaite rejoindre
l'angleterre maintenant parce que son
contrat s'arrête à la fin d'année
exactement comme com bat p au p dg pour
le coup son contrat s'arrête à la fin de
l'année c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que le
barça voulait absolument novembre pour
pas le perdre gratuitement pour
récupérer quelque chose en échange on
parlait d'une somme de 20 millions
d'euros c'est absolument dérisoires plus
par rapport à ce qu'ils avaient coûté au
barça dans les environs des 150 millions
quelque chose comme ça je crois après le
départ de neymar
c'est c'est un joueur qui va sûrement
quitter le barça cet été gratuitement du
côté du psg au moins au niveau des
départs on sait que le club devait
vendre absolument comme chaque fois et
comme chaque fois il n'y a pas eu grand
chose dans le sens des départs on a eu
un prêt de rafinha les notes de sergio
rico a pas grand chose en tout cas n'ont
pas grand chose pour le psg bat c'est
encore un mercato un constat d'échec en
tout cas dans le sens des départs dont
l'essence d'arrivée il n'y a pas eu il
ya rien eu non plus en même temps
le psg peut être déçu de ce mercato le
psg n'a pas réussi à faire ce qu'il
devait faire marot et cardy est toujours
là il toujours indésirable
layvin kurzawa est toujours là peut-être
qu'il va partir dans les dernières
heures ça a été encore se faire qu'en
savoir le rappel qui a joué un match
c'est le trophée des champions au mois
d'août depuis plus rien oui à ce niveau
là le psg dans l'échec le psg qui
risquent en plus de voir mbappé partir
gratuitement encore un échec à ce niveau
là ça commençait à faire beaucoup pour
le psg et sportivement en plus on avait
parlé d'un mercato estival exceptionnel
dans les arrivées mais s'ils y donnent à
roma et compagnie ça ne se traduit pas
totalement aujourd'hui dans l'aspect
sportif en tout cas pour la ligue des
champions pour l'objectif numéro 1 du
psg ça n'est pas de très bon augure
jusqu'ici pour l'instant le psg est
plutôt sous pression et n'a pas vraiment
convaincu sur le mercato effectivement
il enverra donc ce que ça donnera face
au real de madrid en huitièmes de finale
de d2 et des champions parce que ça va
quand même arriver assez vite on va
parler d'un autre club en france lyon
lyon qui a été l'un des grands
animateurs de cette fin de mercato
puisque on va parler déjà dans le sens
du dd par bruno desmarais ce qui va
partir après deux ans à lyon tu vas
particules qui part à newcastle ouais
c'est un transfert un peu surprenant
tout cas du côté de lyon parce que c'est
vraiment un jour que lui on voulait
conserver c'est un titulaire
indiscutable sous peter bosch on voyait
difficilement un tel joueur en tout cas
un tel titulaire partir cet hiver d'un
autre côté il ya les neuf qui un sac en
60 millions d'euros c'est quand même
très doux si de dire non ça se rapproche
du record de ventes de lyon qui était de
tanguy don bailey pour 60 millions
immobile et on reparlera d'ailleurs
et bruno guy mares ça peut paraître
assez étonnant quand même ce choix
sportifs en tout cas pour lui de
rejoindre newcastle 19e de premier
league alors certes ya tout ce projet un
petit peu ambitieux un petit peu un
petit peu floue en même temps on ne sait
pas trop où ça va mais ce nouveau
propriétaire saoudien d'un côté on peut
être excité d'un côté on peut se dire
que et aucune garantie ça c'est une
réalité surtout quand on voit quelques
mares a été cité aussi à arsenal à
tottenham qui sont quand même des clubs
mieux structuré mieux armées et mieux
aujourd'hui sportivement au jour j c'est
absolument pas photo c'est un choix
quand même assez étonnant pour bruit
donc y mares d'un point de vue sportif
c'est une perte pour lyon mais en même
temps qu'il va sûrement être très bien
qui va être bien bien des palais et qui
va justement d'en parler on peut quand
même faire un petit point sur newcastle
parce que newcastle a été racheté ils
ont eu beaucoup d'argent et on a dit que
pendant ce mercato d'hiver et d'aller se
reconstruire une armada offensive
on en parle dans énormément de rumeurs
de transfert mais pour autant ils n'ont
pas eu énormément on à bruno guy mariage
on a car entre pierre qui joue à
l'atletico madrid et à part ça c'est pas
non plus un mercato et xl va dire oui
c'est vrai que c'est qu'elle a à peu
près 90% des joueurs de la planète ont
été annoncés à une casserole si vous
n'avez pas été annoncé qu'un seul c'est
que vous n'êtes pas très bon visiblement
donc pour newcastle c'est vrai que le
mercato n'est pas aussi extraordinaire
que ce qu'on aurait pu penser qu'ils
ratent rippert c'est plutôt une bonne
recrue un joueur qui voulait partir de
l'atletico et qui a pourtant avait sa
place en plus simple et chico qui est
plus un mal du pays c'est une bonne
recrue qui me reste c'est très fort même
si c'est très cher il ya d'autres
recrues qui seront à surveiller chris
wood notamment de burnley sur le rapport
qualité prix en tout cas on peut quand
même s'interroger sur newcastle est ce
que l'argent était si bien dépensé que
ça pour se maintenir en 1re ligue c'est
plutôt ambitieux maintenant il faut que
tous apprennent tout de suite parce que
c'est la question du maintien en pagne à
l'égalité réelle le club 19e aujourd'hui
un club racheté comme ça ne peut pas se
permettre de descendre aussitôt il ne
peut pas se permettre de vendre ensuite
un projet sportif est de convaincre
d'autres joueurs de venir sur le papier
c'est plutôt intéressant mais ça demande
vraiment confirmation très très vite
effectivement pour réussir pour réussir
à confirmer à rester en premier league
ce qui est très important que tu lisais
pour les finances du club
on va repartir sur lyon avec guillon qui
perd à bruno l'image mais qui va
accueillir alors rien d'officiel encore
mais a priori tanguy et l'anglais et
romain febvre way est un guide mon bel
air ça c'est une énorme surprise
puisqu'il ya quelques jours on annonçait
plus tôt et j'ai donc entre le psg et
lyon il ya quand même une sacrée
différence aujourd'hui entre le
classement de ligue 1 le fait de jouer
la ligue 2 l'as cannes eric des
champions et de vouloir faire quelque
chose on va dire en ligue europa c'est
une grosse surprise on voyait pas du
tout revenir revenir à lyon
il dirige vers vers un prêt avec une
option d'achat qui d'après plusieurs
médias serait d'environ 60 millions
d'euros autant dire que lyon ne
dépensera un chat mais 60 millions
d'euros à nouveau pour pour un joueur
qui l'a vendue justement 60 millions il
ya seulement seulement trois ans je
crois
c'est une énorme surprise c'est un
renfort de poids c'est un renfort de
poids pour compenser la perte de
guimarães c'est un genre qu'il faut
relancer qui était très irrégulier à
tottenham qui étaient poussés dehors
c'est quand même un international
français un ancien international
français qui a fait qu'une saison à lyon
mais il fait ils sont extraordinaires et
oui c'est ainsi une recrue très très
forte un vrai box-to-box qui peut
importer des premiers jours à lyon dans
un environnement on imagine qu'ils ne
sera assez familier en tout cas où il va
vouloir s'épanouir une vaste s'en tire
plutôt bien où il sera bien accueilli
c'est quand même un sacré coup de gueule
parce qu'il ya encore des joueurs qui
étaient là où lui y était on pense à
oussama voir anthony lopes c'est pas un
club qui a également changé depuis qu'il
est parti en fin mai un peu mais
exactement oui il va retrouver des
joueurs des gens qu'il connaît dans ce
club il a fait qu'un an mais il a fait
un temps vraiment marquant assez pour
être acheté 60 millions par par
tottenham aujourd'hui elle pas trop sa
place il est prêté ce sera peut-être
pour se relancer alouettes pour ensuite
de nouveau s'imposer à tottenham dans un
club encore plus gros pour lui et pour
l'ol c'est tout bénéfique mais parce
qu'il ya quand même aussi une coupe du
monde quelque part dans sa tête pour lui
aussi c'est l'idée c'est d'avoir du
temps de jeu pour pour essayer de se
mouiller
de se montrer qui pourquoi pas attraper
le bon wagon pour être à la coupe du
monde ouais pourquoi pas en tout cas au
moins regagner des points un petit peu
dans les cimes de didier deschamps même
si on sait que deschamps ne change que
très très peu sa liste est rarement au
dernier moment comme ça pour rappeler
des joueurs surtout dans un secteur
assez concurrentiels pour qu au milieu
de terrain où il ya déjà beaucoup
beaucoup de batailles mais les oui en
tout cas sur le transfert on a
l'impression que les trois parties sont
finalement gagnante peut-être un peu
moins autonomes qui va quand même
sûrement payer une partie du salaire de
bombay si jamais ça marche pas ce serait
un petit échec pour tottenham mais c'est
un vrai pari un très joli pari en tout
cas pour lyon et pour noble et voilà
vous n'hésitez pas à vous dans vos les
commentaires de ceux là il va nous dire
ce que vous en pensez si vous avez
d'autres questions sur des rumeurs que
vous avez vu pour vous que vous donne un
peu ce qu'on en 16 notre avis sur les
sources parce que mon mercato ya
toujours beaucoup d'informations il faut
arriver à trier et toi tu as c'est
l'habitude de faire ça on va dire pour
voir un peu ce qui est sérieux et ce qui
ne l'est pas il ya une autre arrivée qui
arrive à notre arrivée qui ait pitié
prévu du côté de lyon celle de romain
febvre romain febvre de brest qui
explose de à brest depuis très longtemps
et qui est qui est aussi une très bonne
recrue pour pour les pylônes et ouais il
est annoncé sur le départ depuis depuis
un moment romain febvre s'est vraiment
imposé comme un comme un joueur
important en ligue 1 un vrai leader
technique au stade brestois un ailier
qui est capable de créer de faire la
passe de marquer vraiment un joueur
assez complet en tout cas que commencer
à avoir un bagage assez complet dans le
secteur offensif c'est une belle recrue
pour pour l'ol c'est une progression
finalement assez assez assez logique de
passer de brest à lyon a peut-être un
plus grand club on sait qu'il a souvent
fait les clins d'oeil à l'ac milan qui
est un club qu'il aime depuis toujours
et qui était déjà un petit peu de choses
sur lui sur les derniers mercato le
transfert ne s'est pas fait l'été
dernier ça la salle à verser affecté
d'ailleurs je sais ça ça l'avait un peu
un peu frustré il avait souvent envoyé
les petits messages par médias
interposés en espérant que le milan
reviennent de pouvoir rejouer pouvoir
jouer un jour en tout cas dans un club
de cette envergure l'olympique lyonnais
c'est une bonne étape pour lui c'est une
bonne recrue pour pourront lui aussi
avoir un petit peu avec les mouvements
qui pourront ça collait à ça parce que
les bulles
cette rumeur était venu juste après le
départ de guy marais c'est que c'est pas
du tout les mêmes joueurs clairement pas
c'est pas du tout les mêmes postes donc
on verra la place qui se trouve à lyon
avec avoir peut-être peut-être que c'est
lui aussi qui va devoir prendre la suite
prendre les rênes de cette attaque
lyonnaise si avoir 120 à l'été prochain
ce qui est apte à ses dribbles assez
probable même le temps qu'on en parle
oui tout à fait et voilà c'est une bonne
recrue en tout cas pour pour l'ol sur le
plan offensif effectivement on
rappellera un très bon très bon élément
qui fait lui qui fait le bonheur de
brest ça va être un vrai coup dur pour
brest de perdre son maître à jouer oui
en tout cas sûrement son son meilleur
joueur surtout dans le secteur offensif
c'est un joueur qui est extrêmement
important je crois qu'il est à 8 buts 6
passes décisives cette saison oui dans
la course au maintien ça va être un
petit peu compliqué le départ se fait
maintenant en cours de saison oui c'est
quand même un petit coup dur pour brest
effectivement on peut parler maintenant
de lille autre club qui a animé ce
mercredi vers avec d'abord le des bleus
le départ dit koné je n'attendais
connaît très bon très bon joueur joueur
international français mais assez
régulier ouais très irrégulier
là aussi c'était un joueur qui a été
souvent annoncées dans les rumeurs l'été
dernier divers d'avant on se demander
quand est-ce qu'ils allaient partir je
crois qu'il était en fin de contrat
d'ailleurs une à lille dans son son cas
devait se résoudre maintenant ou jamais
pour lydon pour le perdre gratuitement
ensuite score était quand même assez
assez dommage
est ce que c'est un joueur qui va
énormément énormément manqué à lille je
n'en suis pas sûr parce que le losc a su
vraiment se réinventer en attaque avec
jean étant david qui est parfaitement
acclimaté aujourd'hui bora qui masque un
petit peu dans le dur je met en branle
bas qui lui aussi un peu comme il
connaît l'était sur courant alternatif
c'est un joueur qui sera intéressant à
suivre en tout cas la fiorentina si
jamais il arrive à peut-être trouvé un
peu plus son rythme dans ce championnat
dans une équipe
qui peut un petit peut s'apparenter au
losc aujourd'hui en tout cas quand on
regarde les classements en italie et en
france ce serait un joueur à suivre pour
l'équipe de france aussi maintenant
effectivement c'est un joueur
extrêmement irrégulier qui a besoin
vraiment de franchir ce palier assez
rapidement s'il veut s'il veut vraiment
s'imposer et en tout cas franchir ce cap
en équipe de france et en club et pour
le remplacer alors pour le remplacer où
il ou non mais c'est lille a misé sur
sur un revenant une nouvelle fois c'est
assez hatem ben arfa hatem ben arfa qui
enchaîne quand même les depuis son
passage à nice qui commence quand même à
dater un peu en chaîne les
moules et saison plutôt moyenne on va
dire et qui se relance une nouvelle fois
lille est ce qu'on peut il croire une
nouvelle fois ouais ça fait quatre cinq
ans que l'on essaie on espère retrouver
le vrai hatem ben arfa celui la saison
de nice au celui qu'on a parfois perçus
en angleterre ou à lyon à marseille
si difficile de nourrir franchement
désespoir sur hatem ben arfa son passage
au psg a été raté depuis les passages à
bordeaux ça a été un échec à valladolid
ça n'a pas marché non plus en espagne
c'est difficile d'en attendre grand
chose et je pense pas que lorsque l'on
n'attend grand chose non plus c'est un
joueur qui arrive gratuitement qui peut
toujours sur quelques coups d'éclat
apporter un petit peu de peps à une
équipe qui en aura besoin encore de
cette saison surtout avec effectivement
le départ dit koné et un jonathan bamba
qui est lui aussi assez irrégulier
c'est une petite attraction on va
regarder le losc pour voir si ben arfa
peut faire quelque chose qui peut créer
quelque chose c'est une équipe qui a un
calendrier encore chargé avec la ligue
des champions c'est un joueur qui se
penchent largement encore performer
quand même au niveau de la ligne 1 à
voir si physiquement il peut vraiment
tenir le coup sur six mois en tout cas
sur six mois il n'y a pas de risque pour
lui il n'y a pas de risque pour le loc
c'est une recrue intéressante mais sa
pro ça ne promet pas grand chose ça ne
témoigne pas non plus d'une grande
ambition en tout cas sur le moyen ou
long terme à voir aussi s'il accepte de
tenir un rôle moins important bien sûr
puisqu'il doit plus le calibre qu'il
avait avant et d'accéder d'être plutôt
sur le bord on va dire oui bien sûr
c'est aussi une possibilité car c'est un
joueur qui a bordeaux c'est pas non plus
mal passé il n'est pas parti en claquant
la porte même s'il n'a pas été
flamboyant parce qu'il n'a pas réussi à
tenir sur le rythme de la saison
maintenant c'est un joueur qui a quand
même beaucoup de vécu beaucoup de
bouteilles qui arrive très souriant très
manière très chaleureuse sans se prendre
pour un autre là dessus c'est quand même
assez assez prometteur mais est-ce que
ça va marcher est ce que vraiment il va
apporter un plus au losc ça on peut
encore en douter un petit peu daladier
dans les commentaires qui nous dit
qu'ils viennent mba paix at-il vraiment
signé conclu un accord avec le real
madrid dans le cadre d'une arrivée en
tant qu'agent libre on en parle en début
de live on peut peut-être répéter ce
qu'on dit ce qu est ce qu on dit tout à
l'heure ouais alors d'appel à cette
information du journal allemand bild que
bp serait d'accord avec le real madrid
pour y signer en en juin prochain au
terme de son contrat au psg à ce que
cette information est vraie ou pas on
n'en sait rien en tout cas aucun média
n'a confirmé cette information on va
vraiment attendre sur un sujet pareil
surtout 31 janvier à deux semaines d'un
psg real madrid en ligue des champions
c'est par quand même étonnant que
aujourd'hui il me bat p ait décidé de
signer au real madrid d'écarter l'idée
de prolonger au psg parce que cette idée
semblait encore vive il ya encore un
mois en tout cas c'est ce que disaient
certains médias français dont le
parisien donc on va encore vraiment
attendre là dessus pour l'instant le cam
bape et il n'est pas du tout merci en
tout cas pour cette fin de mercato on
peut parler peut-être de l'om l'om qui
aussi a vraiment animé ce mercato pablo
longoria une nouvelle fois à fait
voilà à jouer pour le port le mercato on
va dire il ne sait pas il n'est pas
resté très tranquille avec beaucoup
d'arrivées comme celle de cédric bakambu
déjà on peut commencer à parler de ça
qui a plutôt réussi ses débuts en plus
avec l'om oui car ici ses débuts qu'à
marquer très vite son territoire pour le
coup avec l'om alors ça fait partie de
ces joueurs dont on ne sait pas du tout
quoi attendre qu'on a un petit peu perdu
de vue en europe qui s'était révélé
externe plutôt révélé imposé à
villarreal mais c'est à quelques années
depuis un passage assez long en chine on
sait pas vraiment comment ça s'est passé
pour lui là-bas on ne sait pas comment
est ce qu'il est ce qu'il revient
physiquement techniquement dans quel
dans quel état d'esprit même si on sait
aujourd'hui que passer en chine ça ne
veut pas dire une fin de carrière on l'a
vu un excellent exemple en espagne ganic
carrasco qu'on pensait terminer qu'à 26
et 27 ans qu'on pensait qu'il allait
faire un trait sur sa canne européenne
ils reviennent chico il a été excellent
donc ça veut pas dire que bakambu
n'apportera rien à l'om pour l'instant
il importe il apporte du poids en
attaque il a peur de la concurrence pour
arcade du smic pour l'instant c'est
plutôt une recrue intéressante et qui ne
coûte rien c'est surtout la force de
même en tout cas sur ce mercato
d'essayer de choper des joueurs qui va
être des bons coups qui peuvent apporter
quelque chose sans prendre de risque non
plus effectivement parce que en plus de
bakambu il ya samuel jego qui est casier
alors ça bulle gigot c'est peut-être un
inconnu du grand public parce que ça
fait quand même un moment qu'il est
parti et qu'il est parti de france mais
c'est quand même c'est comme une valeur
sûre en
en défense centrale oui ça paraît
vraiment être une valeur sûre il était
il était au lokomotiv moscou si je ne
dis pas de bêtises
tac moscou spartak moscou d'ailleurs
plutôt
c'était un titulaire indiscutable la
basse au fils était en fin de contrat
alors il va rejoindre l'omc en juin
prochain donc c'est pas pour tout de
suite mais ça a l'air d'être vraiment un
bon coup parce que c'est un défenseur
donc français passé par arles avignon
qui a quitté la france très tôt et qui
était vraiment établie en russie comme
un joueur très très fiable de ce que
j'ai lu personnellement je parle plus
grands suiveurs du championnat russe
mais de ce que j'ai lu on parle d'un
leader vocal d'un joueur avec un fort
caractère qui va vraiment se faire
apprécier de supporters dans les
fonceurs très solide et capable aussi un
petit peu de relancer alors ça on verra
encore après avec l'om ou en ligue 1
pour le coup l'om est une équipe qui
peut se faire presser face à des équipes
ambitieuses ce qui est un petit peu
moins qu'à dans le championnat russe ou
inhabituels un peu plus à dominer
vraiment de jeu donc on verra ce qu'ils
nient ce qu'ils voient ce niveau là mais
sur l'aspect défensif ça a l'air très
sérieux il a que 28 ans je crois oui
c'est vraiment un joli coup gratuit donc
pour l'om sans indemnité de transfert
c'est très bien joué je pense de la part
de pablo correa et autre recrue en
défense et l'arrivée de que de colo dit
nash qui jouait à arsenal jusque là et
qui va et qui va donc rejoindre l'om
qu'au troisième ce qui était une
pointure mais qui était quand même à mon
connu qui a un peu disparu quand même
depuis un mois wen ont connu alors pour
le coup qui joue à arsenal j'ai envie de
jouer c'est un bien grand mot puisque je
crois qu'il n'a joué que cinq matchs
cette saison il était vraiment dans le
dur surtout parce qu'il a eu des
blessures qui l'ont vraiment s'est
décliné assez assez brutalement je crois
qu'il a 31 ans aujourd'hui il est déjà
son corps son corps a déjà pas mal en
dur et donc on verra vraiment ce qu'il
vaut c'est un joueur qui peut a priori
jouer toujours latéral gauche est ce
qu'il peut toujours à son âge avec les
blessures qu'il a eues ce qu'il a
toujours le coffre surtout à l'ol dans
un jeu quand même parfois un petit peu
énergivores ou st pauli peut avoir
tendance à jouer avec des pistons ou du
coup il faut quand même couvrir une
certaine distance on verra s'il est
vraiment capable de ça aussi c'est
plutôt finalement un défenseur central
un joueur qui peut s'adapter plus à ce
poste-là
on attend un peu plus de voir je pense
qu'entre bakambu que l'asie nage et
gigot c'est le joueur qui conserve le
plus d'interrogations et
l'om qui recrutent beaucoup en défense
centrale donc et qui va peut-être voir
partir des défenseurs on pense à alvaro
on pensa à kayes thatcher du côté de
west ham kpatcha on en parle à chaque
âge à chaque mercato je pense maintenant
différemment c'est vraiment une volonté
de le de l'om de se séparer de ses
joueurs ouais tout à fait alors il ya un
an effectivement chat ça on en parlait
beaucoup à liverpool et son transfert
raté là aussi ils avaient l'avait
beaucoup affecté
son départ a l'air inéluctable ce soit
cet hiver ou l'été prochain cet hiver on
en parle surtout à west ham en ce moment
ça va peut-être se résoudre d'ici d'ici
quelques heures donc on verra ce que ça
donnera maintenant ce n'est pas un
joueur qui s'est rendu indispensable à
l'om comme un william saliba par exemple
en défense c'est un joueur qui a un bon
de sortie
c'est un joueur sur lequel doit elle
espère tirer une plus value alors plus
le temps passe plus ça va être difficile
parce que son contrat un moment donné
arrivera à son terme je crois en 2023
donc c'est il arrivait pour 20 millions
à l'om si je me souviens bien donc ça va
être quand même compliqué aujourd'hui à
joueur de l'om qui ne joue pas tant que
ça à l'eau afin qu'ils jouent mais qu'il
ne venait pas de titulaire à dix quand
indiscutable pardon arriver à le vendre
plus de 20 millions à part d'angleterre
va être compliqué oui ça va être
compliqué en tout cas c'est pas
forcément les prix qui circulent qui ne
dépasse pas vraiment les 20 millions de
ce que raconte la presse anglaise donc
ça va être un petit peu compliqué pour
l'om mais c'est peut-être un joueur qui
arrive est aussi un moment donné où il
l'a vraiment envie de partir ou son
départ son départ à liverpool ça aurait
été un peu ça aurait été un énorme pas
dans sa carrière un énorme pas en avant
ça c'est pas faire west ham soit aussi
un projet très ambitieux on voit
beaucoup cette saison un club qui lutte
pour le top 4 en première ligue est ce
que ce sera une énorme perte pour l'ol
sur cet hiver ce sera un petit coup dur
si jamais il faut perdre lui et elle va
rencontrer à l'aise parce que avec
plusieurs tableaux plusieurs
compétitions à jouer l'effectif que ça
va être un petit peu court sur les six
prochains mois ce sera à surveiller
effectivement du côté de l'om on peut
parler d'un joueur hugo est critique et
qui joue à reims et que dont on parle
beaucoup à newcastle c'est un joueur que
le grand public a découvert cette saison
clairement et qui a de fait un très très
bon début de saison avec huit buts je
crois c'est sale 8 buts en 18 matches
trois de ligue 1 c'est un attaquant
extrêmement prometteur alors on n'a pas
envie de s'enflammer trop non plus parce
que c'est un joueur
20 matches en professionnel 25 matches
c'est un attaquant très jeune 19 ans
seulement mais les promesses sont réels
les premiers sont réels on parle d'un
joueur qui fait plus d'un mètre 90 qui a
une technique assez impressionnante pour
son gabarit si une certaine maturité
dans son jeu
ça n'atteint extrêmement prometteur ce
n'est pas un hasard si jamais newcastle
est prêt à mettre jusqu'à 40 millions
d'euros sur un joueur pareil c'est un
attaquant qu'on verra on verra comment
comment il se développe mais c'est un
nom qui peut vraiment raisonner en tout
cas à l'échelle de la france et de
l'équipe de france dans les années à
venir c'est vraiment un jeune espoir
très prometteur grâce peut rêver
activement en tirer une grosse homme
d'antenne castel qui une fois de plus
essaye de d'inonder le marché
du côté du côté de nantes maintenant que
randall coloma nyon on en a parlé pas
mal lors des précédents live mercato
randall que l'aumônier qui arrive à la
fin de son contrat il va falloir offert
quelque chose d a priori il partirait à
francfort oui à priori à francfort alors
c'est un peu dans le sens des rumeurs
qui allait pas mal ces dernières
semaines donc on part on rappelle que
c'est un joueur en fin de contrat au fc
nantes que les discussions pour une
prolongation n'ont jamais abouti que la
direction nantaise a été pas mal
critiquée sur le sujet parce que c'est
un joueur qui pouvait vraiment rapporter
de l'argent dans une situation
compliquée pour le fc nantes 23 ans
international espoir français qui a eu
de vraies belles performances en plus
sous le maillot bleu
c'est décevant évidemment pour le
scellant de voir un jour à partir comme
ça en fin de contrat un peu un peu par
pas par la porte de derrière j'ai envie
de dire alors à priori devrait rester à
nantes jusqu'à la fin de la saison avant
de rejoindre francfort et de porter le
maillot francfort en allemagne
maintenant oui c'est une déception pour
l'excellente en tout cas d'un point de
vue comptable de ne pas vendre un joueur
pareil qui pouvait l'être se vendre à
15-20 millions d'euros peut-être plus en
faisant un petit peu jouer la
concurrence oui c'est quand même une
vraie une vraie déception pour
l'excellence c'est un genre qui performe
encore aujourd'hui en ligue 1 c'est un
vrai bon attaquant aujourd'hui confirmés
de ligue 1 c'est dommage pour répondre
objectivement du côté de saint-etienne
maintenant saint-etienne qui est dernier
de ligue 1 on tente un peu le tout pour
le tout on peut qu'on peut le dire avec
beaucoup de beaucoup signature sur ce
mercato il ya kim eng al assad at you et
paul bernardo est ce que ça peut marcher
on se rappelle qu'il ya pas si longtemps
c'est dans la même situation et ça avait
marché ouais alors on va on va voir
comment ça prend il ya certains je pense
que ces recrues sont un peu inégal j'en
veux dire que dans le pôle dernière
denis c'est quand même oui une certaine
valeur une certaine valeur sûre en tout
cas un très joli coup par rapport à la
situation de saint-etienne
maintenant on verra aussi la gestion des
gardiens parce que etienne green est
encore là à part a priori ça devaient se
conjuguer avec un départ dtn green qui
aurait pu rapporter pas mal d'argent à
saint-etienne pour l'instant ça n'en
prend pas le chemin donc ça paraît un
peu étonnant parce que les tiers green
pour le coup il était très bon et que
saint-etienne y avait aucun souci
là-dessus donc on verra mais en tout cas
de nice garde a confirmé sa nature on
parle d'un joueur qui a passé plusieurs
mois sans jouer qui pour l'instant
n'apporte pas grand chose à la tête de
saint-etienne
pour le coup on parler de valeurs sûres
et que bernard denis on est sur une
valeur tout saussure avec avic soda tube
donc on va attendre de voir s'il peut
vraiment apporter quelque chose eliaquim
mangala c'est un petit peu pareil
malheureusement avec un cv tout autre
évidemment site internet international
français un joueur important à
manchester city sauf que ça fait
plusieurs mois qu'il n'a pas joué non
plus là aussi on peut on peut assurer de
rien c'est quand même un renfort on va
dire de poids en tout cas d'expérience
pour le groupe qui essaye de construire
de construire pascal dupraz ça reste
assez cohérent de ce point de vue et je
me suis lié jour il signe à lyon qui
piétine à saint-etienne mais c'est un
peu dans la même optique un joueur qu'il
n'a pas joué depuis longtemps et qui
essaye de se relancer finalement c'est
ça on prend un petit peu les joueurs
qu'on peut prendre finalement à
saint-etienne en tout cas les
opportunités qui sont là on est sûr de
prendre les meilleurs mais forcément
quand on est dernier de ligue 1 quand on
est autant l'agonie quand on risque de
descendre en ligue 2 c'est difficile de
convaincre des joueurs de se relancer de
partir pour six mois dans une opération
commando il ya quelques joueurs qui
peuvent le faire mais j'ai avancé des
joueurs qui ont vraiment besoin eux même
de relancer leur carrière qui ne joue
plus du tout et qui disent pas pourquoi
pas c'est peut-être une opportunité en
tout cas où ces joueurs peuvent avoir du
temps de jeu espéré créer quelque chose
alors il ya un club justement qui essaye
de faire ça le 19e de ligue 1 donc
lorient 19e de ligue 1 qui essaye de
recruter romane bürki romane bürki qui
était numéro un gardien numéro 1 à
dortmund ya pas si longtemps et qui
pourrait a priori signal
non ça a l'air un peu fou sa connerie
mais ouais ça a l'air un peu fou et
pourtant ça a l'air ça a l'air assez
assez concret alors c'est vrai qu'il ya
un an il a perdu sa place de titulaire à
dortmund il est pas partie de l'été
dernier aujourd'hui il est là le numéro
deux à dortmund c'est clairement un
gardien qui souhaite qu'ils souhaitent
avoir du temps de jeu il a 31 ans
international suisse
ça serait la transfère absolument
incroyable de circuit il ya un an un
gardien qui était titulaire à dortmund
dauphin du bayern en bundesliga
rejoindre l orient 19e de ligue 1 ça
paraît fou et ça serait un énorme coup
pour lorient à lorient 2 précise paul
mardi apparemment n'a plus du tout la
confiance de christophe pélissier à
cause de performances vraiment d'anti
maintenant lorient estime qu'avec un
gardien vraiment digne de ce nom il ya
moyen en tout cas de grappiller les
derniers points qu'il faut dans la lutte
au maintien romane bürki ça serait un
énorme coup pour le coup effectivement
un gardien de vraiment d'expérience
auprès d'un autre club rapidement angers
angers qui pourrait perdre son meneur de
jeu angelo fille jenny qui est là l'un
de ses meilleurs joueurs à voir son
meilleur joueur et qui pourrait partir
en allemagne oui exactement alors on
parlait de romain febvre à brel c'est en
leaders candidats au fuji nice as écris
ça s'inscrit un petit peu dans cette
idée en tout cas à angers là aussi le
leader assez technique un peu maître à
jouer du sco effectivement un gladbach
un club qui était plutôt ambitieux en
tout cas qui joue un petit peu les
trouble-fête en bundesliga qui s'est un
peu écroulé depuis depuis un peu moins
d'un an qui s'est retrouvé à ne pas être
européen cette année qui a subi des gros
revers qui avait sûrement traîner avec
limogés en cours de saison cette saison
là et pourtant il ya quelques bons
joueurs il y avoir gagné une vraie
colonie française en plus là bas avec
marcus thuram alassane pléa manu connaît
nos salles a plutôt un projet
intéressant tout cas pour fujimi pour
découvrir un championnat comme la
bundesliga maintenant ça serait aussi
dur pour angers dans cette course au
maintien aussi qu'il faut encore valider
oui de teint fluide génie ça sera ça
serait un coup dur c'est pas un joueur
qu'on remplace comme ça surtout au 31
janvier et surtout un 31 janvier c'est
ça aussi la problématique on n'a même
pas parlé aujourd'hui mais c'est que ces
départs romain febvre à brest ça se fait
vraiment au dernier moment donc pour y
pallier là c'est trop tard et on va
juste un peu limité la casse j'ai envie
de dire pour les six mois ici mon avenir
ça serait un coup dur effectivement pour
le sco mais ça sera un projet très
intéressant et black barque pour
profonde jean paul est ce que
globalement ça peut arriver à a encore
as tu as taster là un transfert dont
personne n'a entendu parler et qui se
décante et met un gros transfert alors
gros transferts j'ai envie de dire que
ça dépend un petit peu aussi de quoi on
parle a par exemple je vais reprendre le
cadeau semaine des mails et ça paraît
impensable aujourd'hui que ça se
débloque parce que trop de paramètres
trop de barrage trop de choses qui n'en
prennent pas le chemin surtout à cette
heure là en tout cas là aujourd'hui il
est 15h30 16h
franchement maintenant c'est un peu
compliqué pour que pour que ça se
débloque le temps qu'un joueur se met
d'accord qu'il ya une visite médicale
qu'il ya toute la paperasse pascal
minuit c'est c'est clairement c'est
clairement trop tard il n'y a pas
vraiment de dérogation comme ça
c'est difficile d'imaginer un transfert
dont personne n'a parlé maintenant
quelque chose peut toujours se raviver
un petit peu au dernier moment même si
par exemple le cas d'une semaine des
mails et je pense que c'est un mauvais
exemple parce que je pense pas que ça
puisse se débloquer dans les prochaines
heures on va parler un peu à
l'international maintenant qu'ils
étaient un peu la ligue 1 on peut
commencer peut-être par la belle
histoire de ce mercato fin de l'histoire
c'est christiane eric sehn ondres on se
rappelle à l'euro son arrêt cardiaque il
ne pouvait plus jouer à l'inter il va
retrouver les terrains normalement du
côté de brentford en angleterre
exactement alors ils pouvaient pas jouer
alimentaire parce que en italie la
réglementation n'autorise pas de jouer
avec un défibrillateur et c'est
seulement comme ça aujourd'hui qu'eric
scène peut jouer donc il était un peu
contraint de quitter l'inter de quitter
l'italie pour rebondir ailleurs il
revient en angleterre dans un pays qui
connaît très bien puisqu'il a joué de
2013 à 2020 à tottenham c'est là où il
s'est fait un nom il s'est fait
connaître l'explosion n'a explosé
c'était connaître de tous les fans de
foot
retrouve un football qu'il connaît à
brentford un club qui nourrit assez peu
d'ambition parce que c'est un club qui
n'avait plus connu la d1 anglaise même
pas la première ligne la d1 anglaise
depuis les années 40 donc c'est un club
qui revient de très loin qui aujourd'hui
14e de premier league qui jouent
vraiment sérieusement maintien qui peut
vraiment y croire
pour lui ça à tout ça a tout du monde il
va jouer dans un pays qu'il aime qui va
bien l'accueillir qui va bien traités
ont toutes absolument pas qui m a
ovationné dans tous les stades de
première ligue
sans trop de pression après de ford oui
franchement c'est vraiment là bas
histoire c'est le bon transfert celui
que tout le monde a hâte maintenant de
voir l'offre de voir comment comment il
va jouer du côté de l'angleterre on peut
rester en angleterre un peu avec
liverpool qui a signé luis diaz alors
luis diaz quelqu'un qu'on connaît
énormément en france mais c'est quand
même une valeur très sûre de porto oui
c'est clairement un genre qui s'est
complètement imposé du côté du côté de
porto c'est un joueur qui fait vraiment
la une aujourd'hui des médiocrités les
médias britanniques parce que on parle
d'une indemnité de transfert à 70
millions d'euros ça paraît colossale
pour un joueur que le grand public ne
connaît pas très bien parce qu'il faut
vraiment regarder le fc porto pour
savoir ce que vaut ce que vaut ce joueur
même si on a un petit peu vu aussi en
ligue des champions c'est un attaquant
qui apparaît comme générationnel en tout
cas c'est un joueur extrêmement complet
déjà dans sa palette offensive ce soit
en termes de dribbles de passe de vision
de jeu de sens du but qui a été décisif
dans des matchs importants
ça paraît
un recrutement assez cohérent finalement
avec ce qu'il a montré maintenant à voir
s'il peut confirmer à liverpool dans un
club de cette envergure on sait que la
concurrence offensif est extrêmement
forte à liverpool aujourd'hui avec sa
lame année bien sûr le grand jour avec
djoko shota qui s'est fait une place
devant roberto firmino alors quand même
bientôt fermino pas resté aux avants
indéboulonnable de ce trio qu'il formait
avec salam année donc on verra un petit
peu comment il peut trouver sa place
mais c'est très très prometteur on a
l'impression qu'ils ont toujours un peu
du mal à recruter des nouveaux data
quand on se rappelle de minami nos par
exemple qui devait et qui n'a jamais
réussi à s'imposer non plus oui
exactement donc on verra on verra un
petit peu comme il peut s'acclimater
comment ce joueur peut s'acclimater
aussi à la la première ligue mais en
tout cas c'est très prometteur ça c'est
très excitant je dire en tout cas pour
pour les supporters de liverpool pouvait
parler rapidement d'un joueur aussi en
angleterre ses ventes de bec qui va
partir de manchester united pour
rejoindre everton everton coachée par
fois que l'on parle depuis aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs ventes de bec qui qui qui qui
était un grand joueur à l'ajax équipe
s'est un peu perdu à manchester ouais
tout à fait alors à manchester il s'est
tout simplement jamais imposé que ce
soit sous sol chez rousseau rangnick
aujourd'hui c'est un joueur qui n'a pas
du tout trouvé sa place qui ne
s'acclimate pas à manchester qui en même
temps ne pas toujours eu beaucoup
sachant ce qui était très très rarement
titularisé souvent laissé sur le banc
il était temps quand même pour pour
manchester donc au moins de l'envoyer
quelque part pour qu'il puisse se
relancer pour qu'il puisse avoir une
chance espérer quelque chose pascal ajax
on a vu que c'était un joueur
exceptionnel on l'a vu avec les pays-bas
aussi c'est un international néerlandais
comme ac confirme et pourtant lorsqu'il
arrive à manchester c'est un joueur
qu'on a très hâte de voir everton sous
frank lampard dans plus un joueur qui
avait su quand même exploiter pas mal de
bons joueurs à ces jeunes à chelsea 22
mai qu'il n'a que 24 ans il n'a pas
encore lancé vraiment sa carrière en
angleterre donc on a forcément hâte de
le voir à l'oeuvre il peut encore se
relancer effectivement du côté de doute
et de l'espagne c'est le sait le fc
barcelone aussi qui malgré le fait
qu'ils ne peuvent pas recruter on en
parle toujours beaucoup ils ont
différentes torres en début de mercato
là ils ont signé maintenant adama traoré
de wolverhampton qui revient en fait au
wat barcelone est ce que est ce que
c'est un bon coup je pense que c'est un
coup très intéressant en tout cas par
rapport à la taxe dont dispose le fc
barcelone aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
un joueur qui peut qui peut être un peu
peut-être une pièce manquante en tout
cas pour le barça de xavi on a des
joueurs qui sont capables d'être décisif
dans la surface avec memphis des pailles
donc ce matin dembélé ses rentes torres
en dessous faty évidemment même l'udc de
yong qui montre quand même qui peut
peser dans la surface même si on se
demande si la halle et offre du barça
alors adama traoré pour le coup il a des
statistiques beaucoup plus faible en
terme de buts 2 passes décidé c'est pas
un joueur extrêmement décisive à
wolverhampton par contre c'est un joueur
qui a une vitesse de pointe très
impressionnante qui a une grosse
capacité d'accélération qui peut
vraiment porté le ballon c'est un joueur
qui peut vraiment faire la différence à
ce niveau là et qui peut du coup se
complétait avec les autres profils de
cette équipe du barça c'est un joueur
qu'on a hâte de voir qui connaît plutôt
en tout cas de l'environnement comme l'a
dit qui est passé par le barça plus
jeunes
donc c'est un transfert qui fait assez
sens maintenant on verra aussi par
rapport aux montants dépensés je crois
qu'on parle de 35 millions d'euros
peut-être un montant tête un petit peu
élevé en tout cas par rapport aux
joueurs que c est par rapport au plafond
qu'il peut avoir mais c'est un joueur
qui ne s'est incrite mans qui a plutôt
cohérent je pense en tout cas par
rapport à ce que veut mettre en place le
barça maintenant on parle de pierre
emerick aubameyang qui pourrait
rejoindre le barça est ce que c'est
probable une telle arrivée elle a l'air
assez assez probable il a même été
aperçue déjà à l'aéroport de barcelone a
priori ça va se faire maintenant je
pense que c'est un recrutement qui
conserve quelques zones d'ombré on parle
d'une arrivée en prêt sur six mois
là pour le coup on est plus par rapport
à damas traoré on est plus sur l'envié
d'investir après sur le long terme avec
lui de compter sur lui de miser un petit
peu sur lui sur aubameyang qu'on a un
peu sur une opération commando pour
dépanner en attaque sur six mois pour le
joueur pour se relancer en tout cas pour
retrouver du temps de jeu parce
qu'arsenal y en aura plus du tout il a
été complètement écartée par mikel
arteta il est quelques mésaventures avec
le gabon il n'a pas joué la can donc
c'était très compliqué pour lui pour lui
c'est une opportunité franchement
exception je veux rebondir au fc
barcelone je pense lui et il a besoin de
se relancer après après des saisons très
décevantes du côté d'arsenal c'est ça et
depuis qu'il allait signer une grosse
prolongation de contrat c'était très
compliqué cette saison il a perdu sa
place de manière très logique
sportivement il a vraiment besoin de se
relancer c'est un genre qui conserve
quand même une capacité normalement à
finir les actions qui vient normalement
parce que c'était un peu moins de cas
ces derniers dans c'est un joueur qui a
encore un peu une pointe de vitesse même
si l'âge avance on verra ce qui peut
apporter dans ce barça là on verra si ça
se passe bien aussi dans le vestiaire
parce qu'il y avait un peu ses peurs
justement arsenal que ça ne se passe pas
bien du tout à ce niveau là où il n'a
jamais tant assumer que ça ce statut de
capitaine
c'est quand même un recrutement un peu
plus je trouve
une notion un peu de panique en tout cas
du côté du barça pour le coup qui
essaient de faire venir quelqu'un est
trop il faut trouver quelqu'un sur le
marché effectivement on a aussi anthony
martial le français qui quittent le sol
d'haïti pour rejoindre le fc séville est
ce que là pour le coup ça ressemble
quand même un peu un bon coup pour les
deux parties oui tout à fait anthony
martial il avait vraiment vraiment
besoin de partir parce qu'on comptait
pas sur leurs manchester united parce
qu'ils n'arrivent à perdre ils
n'arrivaient pas à s'imposer dans cette
attaque extrêmement riche même s'il a
parfois peut-être mérité un petit peu
plus sa chance et un petit peu plus de
temps de jeu où il n'a pas toujours été
très bien utiliser non plus part parce
le cher il était temps pour lui vraiment
se relancer aussi pour sa place dans
l'équipe de france où il avait un moment
donné il avait marqué je crois à la
trêve 2 peut-être septembre octobre je
sais pas exactement mais il avait
retrouvé en tout cas un petit peu le
sourire à ce niveau là mais pour aller
au mondial trimestre quand même
compliqué pour lui il va falloir
vraiment qu'il se relance a sévi
il arrive assez vite dans un club qui
est dauphin du real madrid en liga
sportivement il après une très belle
opportunité
maintenant on verra comment il jouera
là-bas est-ce qu'il jouera plus dans
l'art est un rôle de véritable avant
centre est ce qu'il aura plus sur un
côté ou c'est peut-être là où il est le
plus finalement impactant lorsqu'il
revient sur son pied droit ou c'est un
jour vraiment qui peut finalement
s'acclimater à pas mal de configuration
je pense offensive donc assez vis c'est
très intéressant et pour lui pour
manchester ça paraissait être la
meilleure option qui vient donc on verra
si si si ça marche et s'il arrive à
s'imposer pour pourquoi pas arriver au
mondial même si on en fait trop ou on
imagine bien il part quand même d'assez
loin on peut parler un peu de l'italie
rapidement avec que vlahovic le widget
fiorentina qui signa la juge alors nous
deux en france c'est pas quelque chose
qui nous intéresse ce qui nous intéresse
qui nous qui nous parle beaucoup et
pourtant de la ville c'est quand même un
énorme espoir qui s'engage du côté de la
juventus ouais c'est le meilleur buteur
de série à cette saison je crois qu'il
avait battu un record de cristiano
ronaldo lui nombre de buts sur une année
civile avec un club italien
c'est un attaquant plus que prometteur
on avait parlé il ya deux ans et on
avait vu l'explosion de berlines
calendes laon ça serait un petit peu
dense est dans cette optique énergique
avec un joueur en plus qui cite
justement comme inspiration surtout
zlatan ibrahimovic mais aussi un peu un
ring à nantes qui a ressemble un petit
peu à ces joueurs là avec un grand
physique près d'un mètre 90 en même
temps assez souple assez agile avec une
vraie technique et un sens du but assez
exceptionnel je crois qu'il était à 18
buts en 21 matches de série a ou quelque
chose comme ça donc c'est un joueur très
très très fort le recrutement le
l'argent que dépense la juventus 70
millions d'euros sur 0,8 il est tout à
fait de logique tout à fait cohérent et
c'est un très gros coup de la juventus
de le recruter maintenant de mettre fin
toute concurrence éventuelle avec
l'inter ou avec peut-être le barça le
real ou que sais-je qui aurait pu
s'intéresser à ce dossier de retweeter
tout de suite de l'engager sur le long
terme c'est vraiment un sacré coup de la
jeune fille 17 buts en 21 matches
effectivement et on comprend bien que la
juventus mondiale et maintenant et d2
comme comme tu disais d'éviter un
possible comment dire enfin une possible
concurrence cdt qui aurait été beaucoup
plus forte ouais c'est un message fort
aussi parce que c'est une équipe qui en
france yves m'envoie cette saison qui
est vraiment apathique pour pas dire
pathétique sous allegri s'est
malheureusement le cliché d'aller
griller d'une équipe très solide
derrière qui a très peu d'ambition dans
le jeu qui n'osent pas grand chose c'est
un message fort surtout dans dans une
situation où part le débat n'a toujours
pas prolongé ça fait presque deux ans
qu'on parle du progression de pablo
dibala la star de la juventus celui qui
a amené normalement en tout cas être
vraiment le porte drapeau de cette
équipe qu'il a en tout cas sur les
derniers mois surtout depuis le départ
de cristiano ronaldo
c'est un message fort en tout cas que la
juventus envoie sur sur le mercato en
italie dans une question de spartak qui
nous parle de newcastle et qu'ils
demandent pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont
tant de mal à faire venir des joueurs la
question c'est aussi pourquoi est ce
qu'ils arrivent à faire venir les jours
c'est parce qu'ils sont très riches et
pourquoi pourquoi n'y arrive pas c'est
parce qu'ils sont 19e de l1 17e je crois
de première ligue je crois qu'ils sont
19e aujourd'hui de première league et
oui bah ça malheureusement ça en dit
long sur le projet sportif ok sur le
long terme ça peut être ambitieux on
peut vendre quelque chose de très sexy
de très jolies mais la réalité elle est
celle ci c'est que les joues maintient
aujourd'hui que dans six mois ils seront
peut-être les gains en deuxième division
et que ce serait un énorme coup dur pour
projet et que c'est un club qui
construit quand même un petit peu un
club plutôt qu'ils ont une équipe
construite dans l'urgence et ce qu'on
sait vraiment où cette équipe va ce
qu'elle commet elle veut jouer c'est
difficile juste de dire on a un gros
chèque voilà signes et ça va être très
bien pour ta carrière c'était un peu
c'est un petit peu bancal j'ai envie de
dire maintenant ça peut convaincre des
joueurs
il est vrai que ce soit qui se sont
enterrés comme ça dans des clubs on leur
a fait miroiter un grand projet et au
final ils sont bloqués dans ce projet et
ils doivent jouer en deuxième division
il n'est pas forcément très torride ça
exactement et en france on peut avoir
l'exemple du psg on peut se dire ah
c'est un projet comme le psg sauf que
des projets comme le pg énormément et la
plupart ça finit pas comme le psg le psg
est une réussite exceptionnelle parce
que c'est un club dont propriétaire
s'est inscrit dans la durée qui a
recruté certains des meilleurs joueurs
du monde qui s'est imposé comme le
meilleur club de son championnat qui a
fait une finale de ligue des champions
mais certains clubs ils finissent sur la
banqueroute c'est ça se rate
complètement donc forcément avec
newcastle il ya quand même un petit peu
de méfiance vous donné par exemple
exemple de bordeaux justement parce que
bordeaux a fait signer laurent koscielny
par exemple en disant voilà on va
arriver on va mettre des mots a fait des
voyages on va jouer la ligue des
champions
finalement aujourd'hui c'est très
compliqué pour bordeaux koscielny ne
joue pas il va là il recrute un peu à
droite à gauche c'est un peu compliqué
ouais c'est un petit peu compliqué même
coché le nic finalement libéré de son
contrat lui qui avait justement dire on
m'avait parlé la ligue des champions et
au final on joue le maintien c'est un
petit peu ça avec bordeaux et bordeaux
qui se retrouve un petit peu comme
saint-etienne pour le coup à jouer le
maintien et à recruter les joueurs
qu'ils peuvent rencontrer voilà marcelo
et
guilavogui guilavogui on le disait juste
avant de commencer ce type' kiki qui
ressemble à quand même une bonne
une bonne affaire oui ça paraît vraiment
un joli coup pour le coup des girondins
et on s'attendait pas forcément à dire
ça en tout cas sur ce mercato ils n'ont
quasiment pas un sou dépensé guilavogui
c'est plutôt pas mal parce que c'est un
joueur qui était encore assez solide en
bundesliga un vrai milieu récupérateur
vraiment dans cette pure tradition de
l'aspect défensif c'est pas un joueur
qui va prendre le ballon qui va en
dribbles et 3 et qui va aller faire une
action décisive dans la surface mais
c'est un joueur qui peut apporter de
julian autres cancers entre cette
défense et ses milieux de terrain on
sait que la défense c'est vraiment le
gros problème des girondins cette saison
je crois qu'ils sont à presque 3 buts
encaissés par match en ligue 1 c'est
catastrophique
donc c'est peut-être un joueur qui peut
apporter cette solidité cette sécurité
même s'il va pas résoudre tous les
problèmes aller tout seul c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt un joli coup pour le coup
et des gendarmes il ya le voit dont on
parle en ligue 1 alors il ne joue pas
c'est blaise matuidi qui joue aux états
unis et qui a priori ne jouerez plus
maintenant aux états unis et qui
pourrait donc pourquoi pas arriver en
france ouais c'est ça alors ça a été un
petit peu j'ai pas dire la science liste
qu'il y avait déjà eu des rumeurs avant
mais lorsque l'inter miami a publié la
liste des numéros pour la saison à venir
aux états unis il n'y avait pas le nom
de blaise matuidi donc autrement dit
blaise matuidi n'est pas enregistrée en
mls pour la saison à venir donc son
départ n'a pas été officialisée mais ça
semble assez clair on a eu une rumeur
assez surprenante qui concernait trois
d'un possible retour de blaise matuidi à
trois puisque c'était son club formateur
c'est là où lycée où il s'est révélé où
il a fait ses premiers pas
ça paraîtrait assez surprenant tout cas
sur l'aspect financier parce que matuidi
quand il est parti aux états unis avant
il était à la juventus c'est un salaire
colossal et ce qui serait prêt à faire
autant de concessions sachant qu'on se
doute que un joueur comme ça champion du
monde c'est un joueur qui va avoir des
propositions des ponts d'or à l'étranger
que ce soit au moyen-orient en chine tu
es encore aux etats-unis dans d'autres
clubs c'est forcément j'ai encore des
propositions maintenant à trois ce qui
est intéressant à noter c'est que il
faut le rappeler ça beaucoup de gens
l'oublient c'est que 3a comme
propriétaire le citigroup qui détient
plusieurs clubs comme manchester city
comme new york city fc c'est un club
intéressant de ce point de vue là qui a
peut-être moyen finalement de faire une
offre qui correspondrait à blaise
matuidi
cela étant voir blaise matuidi venir en
ligue 1 pour finir sa carrière en jouant
le maintien avec 3 ça serait une image
assez je pense exceptionnel une très
belle image mais quand même assez assez
surprenante assez folle pour jouer à
calais pour jouer à cannes adil rami en
plus oui exactement pour le coup pour
retrouver un beau champion en parlant de
de retour il ya bafétimbi gomis qui
jouait en arabie saoudite et qui
normalement devrait signer qui même à
signer sais pas encore si je crois du
côté de galatasaray
bafétimbi gomis qui a encore de très
beaux restes et qui pourrait retourner à
gaza y pour refaire le bonheur de ce
club turc ouais exactement alors il a
fait qu'une saison mais quelle saison
amis je crois 32 buts en 42 matches donc
il a été extrêmement prolifique c'était
en 2018 2019 si je dis pas de bêtises
ce serait un retour je pense très
apprécié en tout cas en turquie à voir à
quel niveau bien sûr parce que depuis il
a pas mal performé en arabie saoudite
évidemment c'est pas le même championnat
c'est pas le même football et l'âge
avançant est ce que c'est encore le même
joueur ça ce n'est pas sûr
on a notamment cité son nom du côté de
saint-etienne qui avait
désespérément besoin d'un renfort
offensif aussi de ce côté là où
plusieurs noms circulaient ce sera pas à
saint-etienne a priori ce sera en
turquie avec un gros public dans une
équipe qui a besoin vraiment de
rehausser son niveau qui est un peu en
difficulté dans le championnat turc qui
est assez loin de la tête
c'est plutôt un retour assez cohérent
tout cas pour gomis sur le plan sportif
ça fait plus peut-être un peu plus sens
franchement que saint-etienne pour le
coup très bien mais coûte écoute merci
sébastien d'avoir été avec moi pour pour
ce live si vous n'avez plus votre
question on va s'arrêter ici je n'en
voit plus d'autre je vais remercier
raphaël à l'arrêt vie qui nous a aidé
pour ce live merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis bien évidemment n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner ceux qui sont sûrs qu'ils
regardent sur youtube pour ne rater
aucun de nos futurs live est bien sûr
d'aller voir sur le site du figaro la
rubrique sport pour voir toutes les
dernières infos du mercato puisque ça
finit à minuit et on peut peut-être
avoir encore quelques surprises c'est ça
on aura un live qui va se tenir jusqu'à
une heure du matin donc pour le coup
normalement on va avoir encore pas mal
de noël oui parce que on dit minuit mais
parfois des officialisations qui
arrivent vers 00h20 mais bien sûr il ya
des s'officialise ans qui peuvent tomber
le lendemain matin qui peuvent être
annoncés qu'à ce moment là le temps
vraiment que tout soit fait que la
paperasse soient bien faites
correctement et que tout le club prenne
le temps de bien annoncer le transfert
ça peut prendre encore quelques heures
après la halle la fermeture du mercato
effectivement ben écoutez merci beaucoup
en tout cas merci à toi sébastien encore
une fois et je